5 25 and your Friday morning what's cool
at school how about a homeschooled High
School flooders from Southern Nevada
making it to the finals of the United
States Marine band concerto competition
in Washington D.C
[Music]
Elizabeth hebbing from Henderson was one
of only seven high school students from
all over the country in the competition
here playing her heart out on composer
otar gordelli's flute concerto Opus 8 at
the John Philip Sousa van Hall she
memorized the entire 11 minute plus
piece and nailed it
the director of the president's own band
Colonel Jason fedig says the
competition's been going on for 15 years
and over those 15 years we have met so
many incredible Young Artists and it's
just been such a joy to watch them as
their lives and their life with music
has continued
and even though Elizabeth did not finish
in the top three her perseverance and
polish are deserving of some Hometown
recognition
fantastic now Elizabeth has also played
here in town with the Las Vegas Young
Artists Orchestra he's got a bright
future ahead of her wherever she goes
you know we always want to know what's
cool at school you got something let us
know cool at school under the Community
tab of our website or just email cool at
school at 8newsnow.com